AND IT'S ALL A STUPID JOKE.
AMAZINGLY A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
POWER FELL FOR IT.
CONGRESSMAN RON DESANTIS IS
A REPUBLICAN REPRESENTING
THE STATE OF FLORIDA AND HE
JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
>> GOOD EVENING.
>> Tucker: THE MEETING THAT
SUSAN RICE DESCRIBES HAD HER
EMAIL THE VICE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT SALLY YATES
AND COMEY IS REALLY
REVEALING.
TRUMP WAS ACCUSED OF
CONSIDERING OBAMA FOREIGN
WITH THE BIRTHER STUFF.
OBAMA DID CONSIDER TRUMP
FOREIGN, A FOREIGN AGENT.
CAN A SITTING PRESIDENT DENY
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS,
PRESIDENT?
>> I DON'T SEE HOW YOU CAN
DO THAT.
I MEAN, JUST THINK ABOUT
WHAT YATES WAS ON TO AT THE
TIME WITH MICHAEL FLYNN MET
WITH KISLYAK, THE RUSSIAN
AMBASSADOR.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY SHE SENT THE FBI AGENTS
TO FLYNN ONCE HE GOT IN.
SO THEY WERE CREATING SOME
TYPE OF BOOGIE MAN REALLY
OUT OF FLYNN ACTING LIKE ANY
INCOMING NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR WOULD.
>> Tucker: A PRESIDENT'S
AUTHORITY AND LEGITIMACY
COMES FROM VOTERS WINNING AN
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES YOU THE
PRESIDENT.
HOW CAN ONE PRESIDENT SAY I
DON'T THINK THE NEXT GUY
SHOULD HAVE THIS.
I DON'T THINK IS HE WORTHY
OF THIS INFORMATION.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPROPER TO
DO THAT.  IT'S INTERESTING.
THIS JANUARY 5TH MEETING IN
THE OVAL WITH COMEY, WHAT
DID COMEY DO THAT VERY NEXT
DAY?
THAT WAS WHEN HE BRIEFED
TRUMP ON THE DOSSIER.
HE WENT TO TRUMP TOWER.
HE SHOWED HIM THE DOSSIER.
THAT EVENTUALLY GOT LEAKED
TO CNN AND THEN THAT ALLOWED
THE DOSSIER TO GET PUT OUT
INTO THE BLOODSTREAM.
ALSO, DURING THIS WHOLE
TRANSITION TIME HAVE YOU AN
UNPRECEDENTED CAMPAIGN OF
LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION DESIGNED TO PUT
A CLOUD OVER TRUMP'S
INCOMING PRESIDENCY.
SO I THINK SUSAN RICE HAS A
LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT SHE IS
GOING TO HAVE TO ANSWER.
WHY WOULD YOU ALL OF A
SUDDEN RIGHT AS YOU ARE
LEAVING THE WHITE HOUSE DO
THAT EMAIL SAYING OBAMA SAID
DO IT BY THE BOOK?
IT'S JUST A REALLY ODD THING
TO DO.
SHE WAS TRYING TO CREATE A
RECORD AND THE QUESTION IS
WHY DID SHE FEEL THE NEED TO
DO THAT.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S THE
ANSWER?
>> I THINK WE HAVE TO FIND
OUT THE ANSWER.
I THINK IT WAS CLEAR THAT BY
THE TIME TRUMP GOT
INAUGURATED, I MEAN, YOU HAD
THE PERMANENT BUREAUCRACY IN
THE OBAMA HOLDOVERS.
THEY WERE PUTTING, FEEDING
INFORMATION TO THE PRESS ON
A DAILY BASIS.
THE FIRST TWO OR THREE
MONTHS OF HIS ADMINISTRATION
WAS CONSTANT BOMBSHELL
REPORTS, QUOTE, UNQUOTE, ALL
BASED ON ANONYMOUS SOURCES,
ALL BASED ON FORMER OR
CURRENT U.S. OFFICIALS.
AND THAT REALLY STARTED FROM
THE DAY HE GOT ELECTED ALL
THE WAY UNTIL THE
APPOINTMENT OF ROBERT
MUELLER AS SPECIAL COUNSEL.
>> Tucker: THE DOSSIER
ITSELF WHICH IS THE CENTER
THE PUBLIC CONSUMPTION
CLAIMS THAT TRUMP WAS BEING
CULTIVATED BY RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE FOREVER FIVE
YEARS PRIOR TO BECOMING
PRESIDENT IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE THAT'S TRUE?
>> NO EVIDENCE THAT THAT'S
TRUE.
THINK ABOUT EVEN WHAT THEY
USED FOR CARTER PAGE.
I MEAN, THE IDEA THAT THE
RUSSIAN OIL COMPANY --
ENERGY COMPANY WAS GOING TO
GIVE HIM 10% STAKE OR 20%
STAKE IN A COMPANY THAT IS
SO BIG THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
$10 BILLION THAT THEY WERE
GOING TO GIVE TO CARTER PAGE
AND THE FBI USED THAT TO GET
SURVEILLANCE.
SO THE ONLY THING THAT HAS
DEFINITELY BEEN CORROBORATED
IS THAT CARTER PAGE DID
TRAVEL TO RUSSIA DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
DID HE THAT.
HE GAVE A PUBLIC SPEECH.
NONE OF THE OTHER KEY FACTS
HAVE BEEN CORROBORATED AT
ALL.
>> Tucker: NOT SURPRISINGLY.
AM I OVERSTATING IT WHEN I
SAY AS A NORMAL PERSON
READINGS THE DOSSIER IT
SEEMS PRIMA FACIE ABSURD.
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BE A MORON
TO TAKE THAT AT FACE VALUE.
>> THAT'S MY REACTION TO IT
IT'S SPECTACULAR AND
SOMETHING THAT COMEY WAS
ACTUALLY RIGHT ABOUT.